first of all i feel like i have to tell
you i was watching this movie over the
weekend and it started thunderstorming
outside which i feel like just led the
perfect ambiance to the whole experience
so that's perfect i mean that's the best
way to watch a horror film on a rainy
night right but i feel like it really
for me kind of enhanced the experience
because this movie feels like something
i can really only describe as like a
modern gothic
um it definitely has that sensibility
but i would love to know what drew you
to this project initially was it reading
the script did you realize you wanted to
be involved at some other point like
what was the draw for you
i mean look i've been wanting to make a
horror film since uh the day i decided
to becoming a filmmaker which was when i
was 12 years old um i grew up watching
you know
jaws and alien and the omen and psycho
and the birds and i i've always been
drawn to this genre um and so this was
just a dream come true to be able to
tell a horror story but also i love
vampires and when i read blair butler's
script and it was saw that it was a
modern origin story of one of the brides
of dracula i was just like oh sold you
know i hadn't seen that before it felt
fresh like you said it's contemporary
but it's also gothic it's got you know
throwbacks to the old kind of world but
also some things that are really modern
um and also to be honest it was evie's
character she's this 24 year old 26 year
old artist living in new york uh
struggling to get by and i moved to new
york when i was 24 and didn't know a
soul in the world to become a filmmaker
and um i thought that was a character
that was really identifiable and
sometimes you can feel lonely in a big
city and she's really craving human
connection and and that's kind of where
the story goes awry
one of the things i definitely wanted to
ask you about was hiring a female-led
creative team
why was that important to you and what
were the ways in which having that
perspective on this project really made
an impact yeah i mean it's wildly
important to me i
hired my first cinematographer autumn
aiken who uh worked on the light of the
moon my first feature with me
um and all of our creative hods had the
department on set were women and to me
it's just like a difference of
perspective when you get something told
time and time again it's not actually
just like a man versus woman thing it's
like
why do i want to watch the same film
made by the same kind of people as soon
as you add diversity to the mix whether
that's uh you know race religion
background sexuality gender whatever it
is uh you're going to get a more
interesting film just because it hasn't
been done before um and so yeah simply i
wanted to keep it fresh and if you and
you want to do that and also we need
more women in the business so of course
i'm going to hire women
i have to ask you about where this was
filmed because the setting is gorgeous
but really lends a sense of place to the
story what were you most excited about
in getting to film on location and where
did you film specifically just for
people that might not know yeah so we
filmed in hungary um for six months and
we were obviously having hungry
uh stand in the place of new york and in
end of countryside england and so
finding the right style and the right
architectural style was really important
and we got this backstage tour of all
these beautiful castles throughout
hungary which was just for someone who's
like a history buff was just a delight
but when i walked up to this castle in
madison the one that we used in the film
it was in the tudor english style i was
like oh this is and it was so gothic i
just thought oh this is it but then when
i found out that the person who who
built the castle was the great great
grandson of madame barkery who if you
don't know was called countess dracula
or the blood contest because she used to
bathe in the blood of virgins i was like
oh we have to we have to film in this
castle like there's no other choice um
but it was really great to be in eastern
europe where um vlad the impaler for
those who don't know is
arguably the inspiration for dracula um
you know i got to visit the car uh the
prison where he was held prisoner for 13
years the real vibe impaler you know so
just being surrounded by all that
history was just you know wonderful one
of the ways
that this movie i think really succeeds
is how it kind of weaves beauty and
horror together and i think there's a
lot of ways in which it does it and what
the people might not be aware of but the
production design especially i think you
get a really good sense of how that's
subtly woven together so how did you
kind of try to hide those visuals in
plain sight like where people might not
be expecting them yeah thank you for
noticing um it was definitely at the
forefront of my mind um
so to me it's like when you look at that
beautiful banquet scene when you look at
that rehearsal dinner scene you see all
these decadent food and it's all like
beautiful and colorful and kind of
ornate but when you get closer you
realize it's all rotting underneath it's
all dead it's all falling apart there's
even flies and magnets growing in it so
to me it was about creating that
contrast like you said that beauty and
that horror that romance and that horror
that really goes together between the
upstairs and the downstairs world that's
a clear distinction you know the surface
life of these people is all beautiful
and decadent and sumptuous and when you
go downstairs it's kind of rotting in
the underbelly um so we tried to create
that distinction with light with
production design um with color
uh and that was really fun to play with
and i think like you said it's subtle
and it's something that i don't
necessarily want the audience to know
immediately but i'm glad that you
noticed i'm glad that you brought up the
dinner scene because i feel like there
are genuinely scary moments in this
movie but the dinner scene i think is
unsettling in ways that you can't really
i don't want to spoil until people have
seen it but it's it's a lot um how tough
was that to pull off and and how much
advanced prep did you kind of have to
take in in terms of making that scene
happen yeah that was probably the
hardest thing to film it was um other
than the wedding scene which maybe i
shouldn't mention either but like it's
uh um it both took three days to film
and uh you know i remember peter jackson
saying that one of the hardest films to
see
a sense to film for the lord of the
rings was the dinner scene and i was
like that makes no sense then i realized
oh it's because there's so many angers
and so many looks and so many people to
capture when you're sitting around on a
dining table so there's that first of
all the physical challenge of it but
it's also obviously what happens during
that scene and making sure that everyone
is present everyone is you know ready to
deliver that um there's prosthetics
involved uh there's a lot of different
you know there's cranes involved there's
you know a lot of different things going
on in that scene as you pointed out
um and getting that to all come together
is so difficult but also so joyous
because when you see your crew and your
cast and everyone coming together to
work seamlessly and perfectly to pull
off this impossible shot or this
impossible scene it's just such a and
when you see that it works and you feel
that it works um as a filmmaker that's
just the pinnacle i feel like i have to
ask you about working with natalie and
thomas as your leads i mean the movie
hinges on you know their chemistry how
they work together
i i would just love to know what it was
like to work with them to direct them
you know how collaborative they were
because it really does feel like it's
their movie you know it's evie's movie
but it's also you know walters movie and
they're kind of stories that merge for
the first time absolutely i mean natalie
and thomas are a delight to work with i
could not have asked for a more
uh supportive talented friendly
wonderful number one and number two um
and you know i'm someone who really is a
character an actor focused director and
i whatever i am told i am given in
rehearsal time i always double it and
rehearsal time isn't to me isn't about
going over the scripts and things like
that they can know their lines they can
learn that that's that's their jobs but
it's really about diving into the
backstory of the characters getting to
know each other getting to trust each
other quite often i do these exercises
where i ask 30 questions in while
they're in character um and we all and
we all listen and we all kind of
discover the character while we're in
this room um and that builds trust and
and they build their trust in me they
trust in each other and they respect for
each other um and that's what's really
wildly important um and natalie and
thomas just had each other's back i
could tell that they were such good
friends and still are and um you know it
they made my job easy you know and it
also helps that they're both wildly
attractive
and easy on the eye you know that that
makes chemistry
i think you can see it in the finished
product for sure um i am all at a time
but thank you so much for taking the
time to talk with me about this movie it
is so fun and romantic and sexy and
scary and i i'm really excited for
everyone else to get to see it too so
thank you